the seven kingdoms is a single realm
made up of seven realms that once were
independent kings landing is a capital
city of
westeros it's huge and crowded and
bustling
each of the houses has their heroic
symbol for the baratheons it's a
crown stag robert baratheon
king who took control in his revolutions
he was originally betrothed to wed ned's
sister lyanna but she died in a war
so instead he's he wed the daughter of
another grace house cersei lannister
there was a time i believe when cersei
loved roberts i think she's about to
open herself up to to someone
and all she got was shut down robert's a
good guy in some ways but he's
he's someone who was much better fitted
for winning the crown than he is for
holding it
i'm not trying to honor you i'm trying
to get you to run my kingdom while i
eat drink and haul my way to an early
grave
he's married into a family who are
possibly the most
power hungry really scheming
and ass licking and money grubbing
sometimes i don't know what holds it all
together
i'm married cersei and king robert also
have
three children uh prince joffrey who's
the heir
parent and two younger children prince
tolman and princess myrcella
joffrey is a he's a pretty mean guy
as as a prince he's pretty pompous and
arrogant i'm telling mother
robert has two brothers renly and
stannis
renly is king robert's youngest brother
there's a middle brother stannis who we
meet later on he's grown up in a world
where his brother has conquered his ways
of being king
he's been brought up in the southern
court
very educated i've got seven kingdoms to
rule
one king seven kingdoms you see
how low some of these characters are
prepared to stoop
in order to fulfill their selfish
ambition
ours is the fury these are the words of
the black stag of baratheon
a battle cry echoed throughout the land
in rebellion when i
robert baratheon the first of his name
seized the iron throne from the mad
king aerys targaryen ending a dynasty
nearly 300 years old
house baratheon was born in the wars of
conquest
when aegon the dragon invaded westeros
aegon sent his commander orris baratheon
to take
storm's end argilac the arrogant the
last of the storm kings
foolishly left the safety of his
stronghold
and met the baratheon warlord in open
battle
argilac was soundly defeated and orris
took his lands
his holdings and his daughter
was said to be a half-brother to aegon
targaryen
if this were true a little blood of the
dragon mingled with that of the stag in
those days
the seat of house baratheon is storm's
end
a legendary keep raised in the age of
heroes
it overlooks shipbreakers bay where
legend has it that durran the first
storm king raised the keep with the aid
of bran the builder of house stark
forging a centuries-long connection with
the stormlands and the north
after aegon's conquest of the seven
kingdoms the baratheons remained loyal
enough to the crown while targaryen
kings
came and went but loyalty has its limits
when rhaegar targaryen harris's vile
son and heir abducted lyanna stark
i betrothed my beloved
it was time to act we raised our banners
baratheon stark john aaron and the
tullys
united in rebellion against rhaegar and
his father the mad
king we were victorious and
took the iron throne that bit of
dragon blood in my veins came in well as
it made me a distant relation to the
targaryen dynasty blood of my long-lost
ancestor oris the truth of it is
i took it i sit on the iron throne
i rule the seven kingdoms from the red
keep